[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
endgame class
uh as always my name is caleb denby and
tonight i'm gonna take you through
even more very important rick and games
that
many many people just don't understand
have never looked at
but knowing these reckon games i
guarantee
is going to end up saving you some full
points
some half points you know maybe on the
drawing side on the winning side
knowing these rook end games is
definitely going to result
in some very concrete differences in
your tournament results i can promise
you that
it may not happen immediately but
everybody has their
you know their one story where they had
this work end game
that they could have saved or that they
could have won
but they just missed the idea so last
week we talked a lot about what happens
when you have three pawns on one side of
the board and a past pawn on the other
side
and we specifically focused on one
example when the
stronger side's rook was behind the pawn
and was able to win
and another example when the stronger
side's rook was behind the pawn but was
still unable to break through
uh tonight i want to take a look at the
opposite situation
where the stronger sides rook the the
side with the extra pawn
uh when that rook is actually placed in
front of the pawn
so if these rooks were to be flipped
this would very very clearly
just be straight winning for
white there's no question about it white
would want run the king
run the king over to b6 this rook would
have to leave then a7
a8 and white would just be up a free
rook now obviously with the rooks
flipped
that is not so easy and i want you guys
to uh to get ready to be
well acquainted with this position by
the end of the night because we are
spending uh at least the majority of our
time here if not
the entire lecture on this specific
position
why is that well it's because this
position is
really sort of the the borderline
position
now on the king side let's talk about
our pawn structure we have f2
g3 h4 against f7 g6
h5 now why do we have this setup well
this is really the pawn structure that
both sides
should more or less be aiming to achieve
in these rook and games so you'll often
see let's say
you know we went back a few turns and
our position looked like this
and the pawn was on h7 and the pawn was
on h2 it wouldn't at all be ridiculous
for black to play h5
and white to play h4 before starting
this sort of king march
back out to the center
that's just because this is the most
solid setup
sort of for both sides if white were to
leave
the pawn back on h2 black could very
seriously consider pushing his pawns a
little bit further up the board to try
to make something happen
as we saw in the previous lecture make a
past pawn make a weakness on the king's
side
start trading off pawns to achieve a
draw and if
black would leave this pawn back on h7
then
white would be able to push through with
g4 g5 and start harassing this king
put this king in a box that the queen
that the king just just does not want to
be in
that's why you sort of end up with this
strange looking h4h5 structure
in many many high level rook end games
you'll often see strong grandmasters
sort of
out of nowhere playing the move h4 and
seeing the response of
h5 quite naturally just a good setup for
these three pawns on the king's side
so we have you know sort of the normal
structure on the king's side
now let's talk about the king placement
black's king is actually placed pretty
ideally on f6
if we're back on g7 it just would be a
little bit too
passive we'll see that black's drawing
chances often come
from this king running up the board and
taking all these pawns
and helping push these pawns off the
board while white is busy
trying to promote so f6 better square
than g7
now f5 is a bit of a worse square for
obvious reasons
and perhaps e6 is a reasonable square
as well for the king but f6
a pretty ideal square for this black
black king
and similarly king e3 is a great square
for white's king now i do want to
mention let's say
we had a similar situation but
this was what we were looking at here
let's say white's king was stuck back
on g2 as opposed to out and about on the
e3 square
what's the story of this uh this
position
well to be honest with you this position
should
just be a draw and to understand why
we're going to take a look
a a closer look at the position with
king e3
but it's pretty intuitive if the
position with the king on e3 is pretty
borderline
then if white's king is in a worse spot
the position should be
should be a draw but for the moment
let's talk about
this position here okay our starting
position king
on e3 for white rook on e2
for black now this is perhaps
one of the most talked about the most
analyzed
the most studied positions in all of
rook end games and probably end games
in general now why is that well it's
because there's a lot going on here
behind the scenes and the evaluation of
this position has actually flipped
back and forth many many times over the
years
i myself learned about this position in
devretsky's endgame manual
but he himself cites analysis by
kantorovich
back in 1988 and then
the update kind of came with someone by
the name of stechner
in 2003 and then we'll see a drawing
idea
actually comes even later on by a
different grandmaster
so what's going on here how should white
try to win this game
well i sort of hinted that white often
tries to win this position
by bringing the king over to the pawn on
the queen's side
and removing the rook using the king to
push the pawn forward
and force black to sacrifice the pawn
for the rook
and i feel like that's where a lot of
people's understanding of this rook end
game
sort of ends they say yeah i'm supposed
to like move my king over to the queen's
side
push this pawn somehow and win the game
now those of you who saw the last
lecture will remember that these
positions
tend to always be drawn why is that
well now let's say black passes
white gets the king all the way to the
queen's side but there's nowhere for
this king to hide
from these checks from behind that's why
instead we're talking about the position
with the pawn on
a6 now if white were to try the same
plan
this king would be able to hide on the
a8 square
so let's see what happens if we have two
players who are pretty naive
about this whole rook end game thing and
they're sort of just playing this plan
that i think many people are familiar
with so let's say white starts with king
d4
a perfectly natural response black plays
rook takes f2
white plays king c5 black plays
rook back to a2 for example
let's say king b6 now black
tries to activate the king with
something like king
to f5 let's say rook takes check
king here a7 take this guy
king b7 king takes here
queen take take and
g5 so what's the evaluation of this
position
so far so normal right we just have the
players
playing reasonably normal moves white
playing the plan we're well acquainted
with
and black perhaps not the most
accurately but going after the pawns in
a reasonable manner
well what's going on here is this is
simply a draw white's king is too far
away
and black's pawns are too far advanced
for example king b7
g4 king c6 g3
king king d5 g2 rook g7
king h3 king h2
and black is in time to promote
white will take black will take and
white of course is
is not losing this endgame able to take
this pawn on h5
so perhaps with naive play the most
common result
is going to be a draw now i won't lie to
you i have seen players
uh i myself have lost positions like
this
with the white pieces where i do such a
bad job of getting the king over to the
queen side
that black takes all of my pawns and
then i'm somehow losing with the king
and rook against three pawns
the good news for white is that a very
serious improvement to this plan
was found so what's the improvement to
that plan
well let's start with king d4 and rook
takes
f2 now does anybody in the chat have
suggestions
for how we can improve on white's plan
here
how can we improve on white's plan
how to improve here
there's a better setup that white can
aim for
aside from perhaps the the normal
looking king c5
so yeah the chat has some good ideas
here and we can start actually
by moving the rook let's say to b7 as
someone in the chat has said
and then after rook a2 advancing the
pawn
now what's the problem with this the
problem with this is black is going to
have
the same idea right black is still going
to go king f5
we can perhaps take this king g4
king c5 for example takes king b6
takes g5 and then
uh oh white seems to be down like an
extra tempo based on the previous
position
right black is or white is now perhaps
even in danger of losing if you don't
run very very quickly
with the king so we need to do even
better than that
even better than rook b7 and
this is where the quote-unquote winning
idea
comes from in this position after rook
takes f2
white is in fact actually winning how is
white winning
well white comes up with a plan that
doesn't involve
running the king to the a8 square white
actually has
another way to win without bringing the
king
all the way up to a8 so let's talk about
it
well first white should start with the
move rook to c7
not rook to b7 and we'll understand why
in just a moment
black needs to get behind the pawn to
stop it from promoting rook f3 for
example is useless because after a7
you're not going to take here you have
to come back to a3 anyways
so rook a2 a7 and
now what is black to do
black is sort of in a tough spot here to
be honest with you it's tough to
understand
how black is going to improve uh the
position
right you can pass with the rook but
perhaps then white will have time
to advance with the king so really the
only option here
is to come with king to f5
and now i will give a gold star perhaps
even two gold stars to anyone who can
tell me
the winning idea in this position for
white
gold star is on the line here people i'm
giving away
so many accolades tonight i declared a
road 2000
champion and now two gold stars
unprecedented
unprecedented for me
unprecedented stuff here
so you guys are giving me some moves but
a single move
is not going to get awarded a gold star
anybody can list
the one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10 11
plus seven the 18 legal moves there's
only 18 legal moves
actually there's like 21 if you include
under promotions
anybody could list those and get the
answer right but i need the idea
what is the idea
well we're approaching t we're
approaching that tw
we're approaching that
so what shouldn't you do well the thing
not to do is
the natural rook takes f7 why shouldn't
you do this
well the reason is you are actually only
further advancing
black's play right black doesn't need
all the pawns to draw
black only needs one of these pawns left
to draw and he needs your king on the
other side of the board
so if rook takes f7 it's true that
you're removing the f pawn from the
board which is a generally good thing
but really what you're doing is giving
black extra tempi
to take off your last pawns and at the
worst case
promote the h-pawn if something you know
awful happens to the g-pawn as well for
example
even this i believe should be just
strictly a draw
the king is going to have to go too far
away and black in the meantime
will advance this h pawn slowly but
surely
so rook takes f7 is the wrong idea all
you do with rick f7 is advance
black's counter play and allow the draw
to become
more clear so let's take a look at the
quote unquote normal plan
right i think everyone would agree king
c5
is the normal plan this is what we've
been taught you bring the king in front
of the pawn
you block the check with the rook now
and you can queen the pawn and this
is a perfectly fine winning strategy
but we'll see here that it's actually
not quite good enough
to win the game in this case black again
is just going to continue with king g4
you can imagine king b6 now being the
move
king takes g3 king to b7
king takes h4 we queen
takes takes and now unfortunately
with g5 it is the same draw that we've
seen before
note that while black does still have an
f pawn here and could draw with the move
f5 g5 is good enough which just further
highlights why
rook takes f7 is wrong right black
doesn't need this f pawn to draw black
just needs any pawn to be able to to
have this drawing idea
so our normal plan doesn't work which is
why we have to get creative here
and that's what a lot of people didn't
understand that's what nobody understood
about this position
until sort of the modern chess era right
and the modern chess era idea
is the sort of paradoxical king to c4
now how does king to c4 make any sense
well
it's got an entirely different winning
strategy altogether
the point of king to c4 is actually
to defend the pawn on g3 through
tactical means
how does that make any sense well after
king to g4
our king is not coming up the board but
actually
coming down to the b3 square
now how does this make any sense well
the point is
we are checking the king and putting the
rook behind the pawn
uh somehow the terrace the famous
terrace rule
rooks belong behind past pawns even
makes an appearance here
and this is the only winning strategy
for white
in this position you bring the king down
the board
with king c4 and king b3 and then you
are able to check your rook
behind the pawn and this is the winning
method so take it from the top one more
time and then we'll we'll analyze the
the continuation here
we started with king d4 black did the
natural rook takes f2
this is sort of the drawing plan we've
been taught you take the pawns on the
king side try to push your pawns and
draw the game
but then we saw white is able to play
the incredible
rook c7 rook a2 a7
now black has no way to improve aside
from king f5 and
white comes up with the crazy crazy idea
of king
to c4 and now if black comes after these
pawns
we have king to b3 with the point of
check
and rook a4 sort of unstoppable
right so rook a6 rook c4 check king g3
rook a4 now of course black has to
sacrifice for the pawn
otherwise queens will happen the stroke
check does no good because you
you can't stop the pawn so rook takes a
seven
rick takes a seven and now king takes h4
is required if black starts pushing the
pawn you're gonna have to
to take this guy anyways there's just no
getting around
taking the h4 pawn white can win with
any number of moves including
just bringing the king back to uh back
to the king's side
so uh king takes h4
first move and now white to move and win
everybody
white to move and win let's see what you
got here let's see what you got
is king c4 the only winning move uh i'm
99 and a half percent sure that it is in
fact the only winning move and we'll
talk about why
in a little bit
we'll talk about why
uh and yeah pip and chuck has the right
idea uh really the only wrong move here
well the only sensible wrong move is
rick takes f7 as i've said before
the f7 pawn doesn't matter the material
doesn't matter
what matters is if black has one pawn
that he is able to push up the board
rook takes f7 is a wasted tempo
in light of g5 so much better is to
bring
the king over to the king's side now
actually all three of these moves are
good enough here
but king to c2 makes the most logical
sense you want to get the king
um to the first rank and sort of a
maneuver known as
outflanking and we'll see that come up
in a second here king g3
is the best try for black here to
actually push the h
pawn and not the g pawn in this case
and we're going to play king d2 or king
d1 or king d3
black should try and push this pawn and
now after king e2
we see why white wanted to get to the
first rank
black now is going to be forced to waste
a tempo to play the move king g2
and that's going to be really important
here if h3
first for example now king f1 is the
only winning move with the point that
after h2
we have successfully driven the king
away and are in time to catch the pawn
so king g2 is a better try for
black now is the time to bring the rook
into play with drift takes f7
and after h3 white only has one move
to win the chess game here only one move
i won't ask you guys to find it but if
you do want to try to you know quiz
yourself here
go ahead pause the video the only
winning move is actually
rook to f2 check and the point is
that black's king was sort of optimally
placed
and now it's going to have to leave that
optimal position
on the next turn why was it optimally
placed well
if you come to g1 now i have rook f4 and
your king is going to be forced into the
corner
and if you come to g3 now once again i
have ideas
of uh of king f1
in the position but rook f6 is the
winning idea now
h2 we take on g6 uh
and now sorry i should say here the
point is
if the king were on g2 i believe
king to h1 is actually the drawing idea
and to show you that
let's take a look h2 check king h1
and the point now is that white actually
can't avoid
stalemate in this position you have to
move the rook away and now you have no
way to stop queening
aside from check and this would be
stalemate so rook f2
critical critical idea if king g1 once
again
then rook f4 and this one is not quite
stalemate
thanks to the king
thanks to sorry not the king but the
extra g pawn so
rook f2 only move to win the game king
g3 is the best try
rook f6 h2 rook g6 check now
king h3 and white to move and win here
uh yes it is the move king f2 uh with
the point being if you queen
i go rook h6 check and win it so the
best try of course
is to make a knights but now after king
f3
king h2 white is able to
win the win the knight here how is white
able to win the night here
well by passing now king h3
obviously loses to checkmate knight g5
knight g3 loses two rook takes and
knight f2 loses to uh
king takes f2 so all in all king c4
the winning idea what's the point the
point is if black goes after these pawns
for example king g4 then we go king b3
and rook c4 to a4 is simply impossible
to stop
and it comes down to the wire there at
the end but this is
just enough for white to win white saves
just enough time
with this winning plan to win against
black's most natural defensive idea
that being said black has other
defensive ideas
for example how do we win after the move
f6
and once again i am going to turn this
one over
to the chat room how do you think we
should continue after the move
f6
king c4 might have not won king c41 as
well you just have to take a bit of a
funny path
what's the winning plan here can we do
the same thing we just saw
can we do the same plan that we just
witnessed
so yeah let's take a look at what
happens if white does try the same thing
i'll give you a hint it doesn't work so
you can play king b3 first and then king
b4 but we'll say king b4 immediately
with the point of rook c5 rook a5
now black unfortunately is going to have
the move king g4 here
as we've seen before and now after king
b3
things are looking very very similar
right we have rook a6
now rook check king takes rook a4
takes takes takes
um sorry not takes if takes
we would see the victory and that we saw
in the previous line where white goes
king c2
comes to f1 or threatens to come to f1
and then
actually can come in with the rook as
well but with the move
f6 black has actually done something
very very useful to the position
and that is negating the need for king
takes h4
with f6 black has with a great foresight
seen this position coming and has
prepared the move g5
to draw the game and this one is going
to be
enough for a draw just by the breadth
of a hair so let's say h takes g5
you know what else f takes g5 the king
comes over
h4 h3
uh h2 and now clearly
we have no way to stop this pawn rook a1
for example rick h7 for example
king g2 and h1 queen is coming
next with a draw so
what's the story what's the story huh
what's the story this move
f6 seems to draw the game right
well not quite not quite unfortunately
is the answer
and now this is the beauty of the move
king
c4 it keeps this idea of king b3 against
king g4
with this checking idea but it's also
close enough to the eighth rank
that white can switch gears after a move
like f6
and the idea is gonna be to go with king
b5
and now uh black is sort of in a tough
spot
you still cannot play this move king to
g4
because in this case
this is not just winning a rook it is
winning the game
because white is queening by force
so important difference here uh
with king b3 or king b4
right away then king g4 and here
hold on i confused myself what were we
looking at okay we were looking at king
g4 king b3
when rook a6 is only winning a rook
because
black is able to sacrifice here but the
point
here the difference now is that of king
g4 we are not just winning a rook but
but we're queening and i neglected to
mention the tricky tricky line
king b4 um
sorry the tricky line f6 king b4
king g4 when after rook b4 check
black to move and draw is the astounding
king h3
to avoid rook c3 to a3 sorry just one
more little nuance that i forgot to
include there
but king h3 is good enough here when
white just has to defend this pawn again
and unfortunately we are not able to uh
to do this
this winning idea of blocking on the a
file
so important nuance there but king b5
the point is now
there's none of that tricky business for
black because rook c4 is coming with
rook a4
immediately that's why king b5 is a good
plan
it stops this king g4 king g3 idea
and at the same time white is able to
come through
to the eighth rank so let's see what
happens king g4 is unplayable because
of rook c4 rook a4 so the best that
black can do is sort of pass
with check rick back to a2
check and rook back to a2
so whoopty do we got the king to the
eighth rank our king is on c8 now i'm
so so glad but how do we actually win
the game
from here what's the winning plan now
all right pip and chuck has a question
that we'll get back to once we find the
winning plan here
not entirely certain what pip and chuck
is asking i might have to ask him to
rephrase that a little bit
but how do we win king v8 rook b7 looks
like a plan
and that is a good plan let's say king
b8
but unfortunately now you know black
still has this king g4
idea right we get to make a big queen
take take
take but the bad news is our king is
going to be too far away
once again this is an important idea to
remember but in this specific
instance our king is just not close
enough so we need to stop king g4
this whole sort of winning idea kind of
revolves around
finding clever ways to make king g4 a
bad move
so what's the way to do it here well the
way to do it here pause if you don't
want to know
if you want to figure it out for
yourself but the way to do it is rook g7
this is the winning move in this
position
what's the point of rook g7 well now
after king g4 we can take on g6
with check and it turns out the move f6
did have some downsides after all
so we would take with check king h3 rook
back to g7
and now black has nothing better than
passing
we can go king b8 rook b1 blocko
rook a1 queen
take take take and what's the difference
here
well now that black doesn't have a g
pawn because we took it for free
we can actually just go rook to g7 check
black
must take this pawn and now black's play
is actually significantly slower
when the king is pinned to to the side
like this
for example f5 f4 f3
f2
and winning the pawn uh sad sad story
for black
so rip g7 and what is black dude is
black resign
well probably black should try this move
of g5 this i think is the best try a bit
better than king g4
so what's happening here well once again
we are going to go king b8
uh if check then rook b7
if take will sorry not take if rook a2
um then sorry
i'm i'm missing my line here but yeah
queening should be good enough in this
case
when after takes takes king g4 now
white is actually just able to uh to
maintain the h pawn or again
go for this line of rook g7
so the best plan once again is king g4
when after queens queens takes takes
king takes g3
we have h takes g5 takes takes here
and once again uh it's gonna be an easy
win for white
because it black takes black like eight
tempe to uh
orchestrate this stalemate position just
to show you
here we come oh sorry this is a bit
better here we come
kings coming down king e4 king h1
king f3 h2 and then the sad sad move for
black is rook a8
when you are not stalemated and you are
in fact
checkmated so always winning by
a hair but winning nonetheless
so let's recap what we've looked at so
far because we have looked at a lot so
far
i told you this whole lecture is just
going to be on this this one position
king d4
is in fact the best winning try for
white and we saw that rook takes f2
is losing to rook c7 uh rook a2
a7 king f5 king c4
and then uh okay pip and trick's
question was why not rook c2 check
takes and queens when you're trying to
achieve some sort of fortress position
with the rook here um so this is a good
question pip and chuck
and my answer to you is that this is
sometimes a fortress position
when the king is on g7 uh with the king
out on f5
unfortunately this is never going to be
a fortress the king is just too weak
here
and perhaps even the move um queen h8 is
is good enough now i don't want to get
bogged down
in the winning method here but i will
tell you with 100
certainty without the king back on g7
this is never going to be a fortress the
king is
too exposed out here on f5 for example
queen g7 to follow
and black is going to have a tough time
keeping track of of this pawn
but okay good question there but what
have we seen
if king f5 king c4 and white has been
winning
in all the lines right if king g4 we
have cleverly stopped this idea
with the idea of king b3 with tempo then
rook c4 rook a4
forcing the wind of the rook and then we
took a look at the drawing idea of
f6 and we do have to switch gears and go
king
b5 this stops king g4 with rook c4 rook
a4
winning not just the rook but promoting
the pawn so black is forced to check us
and then once again we need to stop king
g4 so we go rook g7
and are winning in the ensuing
complications with king
to b8 and a8 queen so there's
one more idea i want to talk about
before we move on from this
we've seen what happens on king g4
we've seen what happens on the clever f6
trying to get g5
now what happens if black simply passes
well once again our winning idea is
going to be to switch gears
and go after the eighth rank with our
king
so for example king to uh b5
for the same reasons king g4 is not
going to be playable here
so let's take a look at check notably f6
would just be transposing
to sort of a a worse version of what
we've
already seen i think ah yeah and white
is just actually winning out right here
with rook c5 check king e6 means
checking over
king g4 means check and over
so better is to keep checking king c6
rook a1
king b7 uh
now king g4 and rook takes f7 and again
i'm mixing up my lines in the study but
that's okay because i think i i do have
it
uh do have it right here for example
check king
c8 rook a1 king
uh rook g7 okay yeah rook g7 was the key
idea
i have remembered where i am a lot of
nuances to cover here
so how do we get here rook a1 and we run
to the eighth rank with our king
and we take the f7 pawn and now the
point is if king takes g3
we are able to win not with a8 queen but
actually with the incredible move
rook f6 now the move that i showed with
rook b1 check is a little bit silly it
sort of just gives white
extra time to play king or to play rook
g7
but king takes g3 is a better try when
white wins with the incredible move
rook f6 the point is we have dual
threats here rook a6
and rook takes g6 and one of those is
going to win the game
for example rook takes on a seven
king takes a seven king takes h4 rook
takes g6
and this is the winning position that we
have seen before
so one more time since i sort of fumbled
over it there once again
a lot of nuances here we are looking at
what happens if black tries to pass
like this and we once again head to the
eighth rank
now rook check is the best that black
can do because if king g4
we have check and over so rook check
king c6 rook back king b7 rook check
uh king back to c8 now
sorry not rook check because that helps
uh helps white's plan by getting the
king to b8
but king g4 instead is a better try when
after takes
king takes we go rook f6 to head to the
a6 square
or capture on g6
and there you go that's pretty much all
there is to check
in in this position king c4 is winning
there really are no other drawing ideas
for black
if king g4 doesn't work due to king b3
then
that idea of coming after the pawn is
out f6
seems like a clever way to draw with
this g5 idea but white is able to
to win with the rook g7 maneuver and
rook a1
just passing the turn back to white is
not enough white will come to the eighth
rank
and is able to finagle his way into a
winning position
as well so that's where the
theoreticians left it
for quite some time it wasn't until i
think around 20 years ago
maybe even more recently that um
they realized that black can do better
than this black can do better than this
so let's go back to our initial position
position
number one here alright remember this
position
this position that we're spending all
lecture in
do gm's memorize all these tricks and
lines i'm sure they refresh themselves
of it but
likely what they do is they've seen this
position and they remember that king d4
is the idea with this king c4 move and
then
they sort of figure out the
complications as they go which i think
is
is a pretty good approach to take in
your own games as well
so king d4 this is what we started with
here
and at first glance it appeared to be a
draw
because white was not getting in front
of the pawn in time after rook takes f2
but now we have seen once and for all
rook takes f2 loses
to rook c7 rook a2 and
a7 when after king f5 really the only
try here
king c4 uh black has no way to continue
that isn't losing the ensuing end game
now can black try anything besides uh
king f5 here maybe but but they should
all also be losing so
what else could black try well if black
just passes then i think
once again we're gonna fall back to this
idea of coming to the eighth rank that
we've seen before
it's sort of just a worse version of
this line
well actually it's just an identical
version of this line
uh where we go king b6 right we've seen
this exact position
after king f5 king c4 rook a1
king b5 well actually no it is a worse
version because white is gaining an
extra tempo there
so uh black can't just pass and perhaps
g5
is the final try but i think uh
yeah h takes g5 is gonna be good enough
here when after rick takes f7
black is going to have a hard time
taking our final g
pawn so is that the end of the story
is black dead lost after the move king
d4
well it turns out no black is
drawing this position does anybody in
the chat room know the drawing idea here
does anybody know how to draw here
how do you draw
yeah great wolf says how many people
will grab f2 without thinking and
i'm willing to bet that is 99 of your
opponents unless you are like
a big time grandmaster but
if you do find yourself on the black
side of these things it's useful
to know how you're supposed to draw
zeke says get a pencil and perhaps that
is most of us
most of our our best chances here sorry
that was
a mess of a sentence but maybe that's
the best chance we're gonna get
but turns out no the drawing idea is
not rook a5 which i don't think is
really helping things i think just king
c4
and you're not really making any
progress on the position but
the drawing idea no wait sorry
i i know that rook a5 draws but it's
just basically a worse version
of the move we're gonna look at which is
g5 turns out
if i'm remembering correctly i might be
wrong on this i think rook a5
leads to a more complicated draw where
black has the same idea of playing g5
but don't worry about that worry about
g5 instead
g5 is the main drawing idea here
and so what do you do with white how do
you play against this well
the best winning try turns out to be
this move king
to d5 uh king c5 on the other hand
is not going to be good enough and we'll
see why in just a few moments but
let's start with king d5 and just trust
me
when i say this is the best winning try
just trust me for now
we'll take a look at other things a
little bit later so king d5
the best winning try uh and now let's
see what happens if black does the
natural
g takes f4 and g takes
sorry now g takes f4 g takes h4 and g
takes h4
at first glance you might think that
this is
a huge improvement for black right you
got the g pawns off the board
and that just leaves two pawns left to
go if you can snap off this h4 pawn
you've got a great pawn
sitting there on h5 but it turns out
white is in fact still winning
this position and the reason for that is
black is once again
in a situation where he is unable to
improve he's actually pretty much
in zhuxvong right now there's no way to
improve the position
for black if you take on f2
well after rook c7 rook a2
uh a7 king f5 king
c6 king g4
um i think i'm getting this right yeah
white to move
and win in this position white to move
and win here
see if you can get a chat room see if
you can get it
white to move and win
well great wolf there's a difference
between getting all the lines straight
within two seconds while talking and
understanding them you know when you
take a moment to think about them
there's a difference there there's a
difference there
so rook takes f7 is unfortunately just a
little bit too slow
the winning idea is to actually come to
the b5 square
and this is the idea that we have seen
before king takes h4
is busted to rook c4 rook a4
and rook takes a7 is once again going to
be a bit too slow here
going to be a bit too slow the king is
coming in
just in time
remember this position remember this one
we make of the knight and white is
winning because the knight is trapped
so king king to g4 doesn't work
sorry we're looking at king f5 king c6
king to g4 doesn't work
and i believe passing is also not going
to be good enough as well
uh this time rook takes f7 is going to
be the idea
and the point now is that we uh
don't lock the king on on the king side
just yet but again
go king b5 when uh black is gonna be
busted
can't take because of this same idea and
if you take here
then we lock the king on the h file once
again
and use this idea to bring our king
right over to here to f3
and i will pass
and go roke8 okay
so king d5 is the best winning try why
is king d5 the best winning try
because after the natural move g takes
h4 g takes h4
black has no way to improve the position
king f5 is going to be the best try but
now after rook f7 check
sorry did i go over king e5 yet i went
over something else didn't i
i went over something else what did i
already go over what did i already go
over here tough
i think i went over king f5 and yeah we
are gonna play i didn't i definitely did
oh i went over rook takes f2 and
whenever rook takes f2
so rook takes f2 doesn't work because we
go back to this idea of rook c7
rook a2 a7 and now after king f5
we can go either king c6 king c5 king c4
these are all the same
because our actual destination is the b5
square
why is our destination the b5 square
well it's what we're going to do
in order to play rook c4 and rook a4
to win the game and this idea works
against um king g4 and then here
once again we force king g4 with the
same exact idea
in order to win okay so rook takes f2
doesn't work which leads us to the move
king f5 this is perhaps black's best try
but again this is not going to be good
enough now we are going to take on f7
and after king g4 go a7 when after king
takes
h4 rook g7 is the winning
move when once again black is finding
himself
locked on the h file and in this case
life is even easier for white
because we still have an an f pawn on
the board
that we can just push up for uh for
victory there
so king d5 is the best winning try
why is king d5 the best winning try well
it makes the move g takes h4
lose the game which is more than king c5
can say
because now after king c5 if we take on
h4
take on h4 uh black has the surprising
move
i think king e5 is the way to draw here
why is king e5 the way to draw here well
now rook takes f7
isn't available because it no longer
comes with
check for example let's say the move
king b6
is played now rook takes f2
is going to be a good one because our
rook has not had the opportunity
to leave the leave the a file to get
this a7 idea going so we can get this
rook c
rook c5 rook a5 idea going none of these
ideas are going to work
because our pawn was still stuck on a6
the best try
is probably rook b7 but now f5 and black
is pushing
for example king a7 here or king c7 here
rook a2 um a7 for example
f4 king b8 f3
queen take take f2
sorry not f2 but king king e4 rook f7
king e3
and at the end of the day
wouldn't you know it chess is a draw
just barely but it is in fact a draw
so that's why king d5
is a better try than king c5 because
after king c5
black is able to take here and play the
move king e5 which
draws the game because king e5 is not
king f5
so you cannot play the move rook takes
f7
notably if you check me here i'll come
back and we are just repeating moves
so king d5 is the best winning try
against this move g5 because g takes h4
now
loses the game in the ensuing
complications but that being said
it's a winning try but does it win the
game
and the answer to that question turns
out to be
no black is able to draw with the move
g4 and i think this is the newest idea
that that has arisen that has
uh led those end game theoreticians to
believe
that this end game is in fact just
strictly
a draw so what's so good about the move
g4
well black is sort of giving himself a
head start in all these pawn races
at the end of the day because this g
pawn is going to be already so far
advanced
and in addition to that this f pawn is
likely going to fall to rook takes f2
that's just something we're not able to
stop
and as such then black will only need to
remove the g3 pawn
before this g pawn becomes very very
relevant now what's the best try
here the best try turns out to be king
to d6
and now i believe rook takes f2
might be losing the game i didn't do a
ton of analysis here but i think rick
takes f2
immediately does in fact lose why does
rook takes f2 lose well white once again
goes rook to c7 after rook a2 we go a7
and we simply aren't able to play the
move king e5
this is why king d6 is again the best
try to stop this idea of king e5 you go
king f5
i take you if you go here then
um uh i think multiple moves win
maybe king c6 is the best and the point
now is that you can't really get to this
pawn
and i'm able to once again
win the game
disaster disaster has struck so
king d6 what's the drawing idea now for
black
well turns out this king can be removed
from the d6 square
best is just to check it away and
now i think rick takes f2 may still be
inaccurate because white does still have
these ideas of rook b7
but black is actually able to check the
king onto the seventh rank
and after king takes b7 now is the time
when black should enact rook takes f2
now that this rook cannot escape
laterally notably the king can't really
go anywhere else if you try king d7
then i'm going to repeat with rook a2
once again
not allowing the rook to leave laterally
if you try king c7 for example
then uh again
rook c2 check if you go king to b8 then
again
rook a2 and again you're not going to be
able to remove this rook
from out in front of your pawn so king
b7 is the best
that white can do and then after rook
takes f2
black is able to draw the game white's
best try
is to go rook a8 then we check and go
uh king a7 notably if the king goes
anywhere else we're gonna check it
forever so king a7 is forced
and now the final moves rook b3
white tries rook h8 to pick up a pawn
but now the simple rook takes g3 is good
enough to win the game
for example rick takes h5 and black to
move and draw there are
a couple paths to the draw now but the
cleanest is king e6
with the point being you are simply
pushing this f pawn up the board
and white is not in time to win the game
for example if something like rook
a5 perhaps the easiest here for black
is to pick up this final pawn
and come back to the eighth rank just in
time
when now once again the game is going to
be
a draw with king f5 among other things i
think even
f5 is good enough to draw but we'll
stick with king f5 it makes the most
sense with what we've been looking at
uh king over two c6 g3
kingdoms closer king f4
rook g8 for example king f3
and no way to stop the queen
no way to stop it so end of the story
right as we approach the one hour mark
g4 is
in fact drawing the game after much
controversy so i did it i taught a whole
one hour lecture on one chest position
can you believe it
and there's not even that many pieces on
the board one hour
for one position that's tough and you
know what the worst thing is
i had more prepared i have more to talk
about in this one chest position
that's the worst thing um that being
said
i think i i am going to call it quits
here uh while i do have more prepared
about this position
i actually wanted to talk to you about
what the story is if it's black to move
so of course
white to move black is barely drawing
with this g5 idea
black to move we actually do have a
slightly easier time
of achieving that draw so let's do a
quick recap
before i call it quits here white's best
winning try is to go king d4
when rook takes f2 loses to the idea of
rook c7
a7 and king c4 with the point being we
want to check and bring the rook behind
the pawn
to improve upon this idea of bringing
the king to the eighth rank we can force
black to sacrifice the rook
under better circumstances so black
should instead try the move g5
in order to get a further advanced pawn
before snatching on f2
now white's best winning try is king d5
when the natural
g takes h4 is going to lose the game
why does it lose the game because black
has no way to improve the position here
we would love to play king e5 but we
just can't do it
so if white plays king c5 then this is
actually enough to draw because we can
improve the king without giving up the f
pawn
so king d5 best winning try g takes h4
barely loses
g4 enough to draw king d6 is the best
winning try but black should check the
king
over to the b7 square then snatch on f2
rook a8 is the best attempt we check the
king to a7
go rook b3 take this pawn off the board
still going and play king e6 the
simplest
to get the f pawn rolling up the board
rook a5 is one try
but black is gonna snap this final pawn
get back to the eighth rank in time
and this ensuing end game is in fact
a draw so there you go one hour lecture
summed up in two minutes obviously we
got very much into the nitty-gritty here
tonight
but let me know if you guys enjoyed this
i know these rook end games
can be very very dry but
perhaps next end game lecture i want to
show you some practical examples where
some very strong players
got these end games wrong and lost games
or didn't win
games because of it just showing you a
little bit of more of the practical use
of these rook end games in action
i really enjoy this side of chess though
i like this side of chess that's very
mathematical
very calculated where it's like yes you
know we know the concrete answers here
there's no guesswork no
necessary uh you know vague principles
there are very specific principles that
work for very specific reasons and we
can know the answers
because we've thought it out let me know
if you enjoy this as well
that is where i'm going to have to call
it for tonight though on the end game
class if you're watching live
please head over to the twitch channel
for a special edition of analyze your
games
maybe those of you who played in the
tournament tonight will be able to send
in some of those games and i will be
happy to analyze them
uh had a blast with that as well but
that's it
thank you guys so much for watching as
always my name is caleb denby and i will
see you
next time
[Music]
you